nos départements en question travaille
toujours ensemble
dans tous les domaines
nous avons connu la baisse de nos
échanges commerciaux l'année dernière de
20%
tandis que cette année je parle de neuf
mois même
8,5 mois à la hausse a constitué plus de
55%
cela veut dire
que non seulement
nous avons
rattrapé notre retard mais nous avons
augmenté nos échanges commerciaux de 30%
de
nos entretiens ne sont pas toujours
facile mais ils sont toujours un
résultat positif puisque nos ministères
sont près toujours à trouver un
compromis pour le bien de chaque partie
les investissements sont aussi en hausse
des deux côtés
nous avons 1,5
milliard de dollars d'investissements
sûrs que dans l'économie russe
tandis que
6,5 milliards d'investissements russes
dans l'économie turque
nous avons des grands projets et tout ce
passe comme prévu
nous avons déjà
lancé le turc stream
ce qui garantit le transit des
hydrocarbures dans des pays européens
et dans ce contexte je voudrais vous
remercier encore une fois
pour votre position conséquente
au cours de la construction de ce
gazoduc qui répondent aux besoins de nos
deux pays
nous voyons que le marché européen du
gaz connaît des turbulences maintenant
mais la turquie et la russie sont en
position stable votre pays se sentent en
position stable
nous continuons la construction de la
centrale atomique ou cueillir
sur l'arène internationale noko paieront
également
avec succès
je pense
à la syrie mais aussi à nos contacts
dans
le règlement en libye
le centre russe le russo turc
chargé de contrôler le cessez le feu à
la frontière de l'azerbaïdjan en arménie
est opérationnel désormais
et cette coopération constitue une
garantie de la stabilité et de la
concertation des positions des parties
en vue de la réconciliation entre ces
deux pays
bien sûr nous avons beaucoup de
questions mais je suis très heureux de
vous voir ici en russie
on peut pas parler de tout faux
téléphones
bienvenus mais c'est le président
moi aussi je vous exprime ma grande
gratitude
comme des visuels comme c'était prévu
avec où c'était toujours en en plaisir
de rencontrer en personne en tête à tête
évidemment cette pandémie des coûts vise
à séparer les amis
le nombre des morts causées par qu'ovide
dépassent des milliers du perse
85 millions de personnes
nonobstant de toutes les mesures prises
notre lutte continue dans des conditions
compliquées
avant tout juste tiens à vous remercier
pour l'assistance accordée pour la lutte
contre les incendies dans notre pays je
veux remercier pour votre contribution
pour votre soutien dans notre lutte
contre des incendies je vous remercie de
ma part personnelle et de la part du
peuple turc
malheureusement lors de cette lutte
contre les incendies
les employés russes on était mort ont
péri comme des vrais héros ensemble avec
des
employés des pompiers turcs lors de
notre conversation téléphonique et nous
en avons déjà parlé mais j'y tiens à
vous exprimer mes condoléances et s'en
sert en profitant de cette occasion de
notre entretien
les amis on se connaît dans le mal
il est à noter que les relations russo
turques dans le domaine politique
commerciale militaire industriel
démontrent une évolution
considérable
nonobstant le fait de présence
de certaines manies
dans ce temps des croisements dans nos
relations commerciales
ont témoigné des tendances positives
je suis persuadé que nous continuons à
développer des relations pour atteindre
de meilleurs résultats
je tiens à vous remercier
pour le soutien accordé dans le domaine
touristique
nous sommes reconnaissants aux citoyens
russes pour leur choix de se reposer sur
le territoire turc et cette année
vous avez parlé de la centrale nucléaire
à akkuyu moi aussi j'ai visité le
chantier
la construction suit les horaires
aux morts
on m'a enfermée que la construction de
la centrale nucléaire sera terminé à
terme
je crois que l'année suivante
nous pourrons inauguré le premier bloc
de la centrale akkuyu
évidemment le travail continue le
chantier 30 ans 1
je veux dire que treize mille personnes
sont employées à ce chantier d'envergure
dont 10000 sondés citoyen turc et 3000
russe
je tiens à noter que
presque la totalité de ses emplois y ont
été formés en russie
ce qui ne fait que témoigner le
renforcement de nos relations
bilatérales
et notre question qui doit être
mentionné
ce sont les pas entrepris par nos deux
pays dans le domaine de l'industrie de
défense
on en parlera
certaines aux fonctionnaires et aux
représentants qui ont posé plusieurs
questions durant l'assemblée générale il
faut leur donner des réponses
parce que
nous avons des pas déjà réalisées et des
processus qui ne sont pas reversi bhl
je crois que le renforcement de nos
relations mais latéral
le renforcement
gagnera de ces projets lancés
nos pas comment dans le domaine de la
régulation cirier non une importance
considérable
la paix dans les régions dépend des
relations russo turque
je vous remercie pour cet accueil qui
nous a été réservé en effet la pandémie
a frappé durement le secteur touristique
partout dans le monde
en
6,8 millions de russes ont visité
la turquie en qualité de touriste
tandis qu'en 2020
seulement 9,5 millions
maintenant nous constatons la
normalisation de la situation et 2,5
millions de russes ont visité la turquie
durant les neuf mois de cette année
cela dépend bien sûr de notre
coopération dans la lutte contre le
rotavirus
elano travaillons de façon positive
également
avec des bots rythme
et je crois que cela va stimuler
l'économie en général mais également en
particulier le secteur touristique
on va en parler bien sûr
merci